تتحدثي عن 500 شاحنه دخلت منذ بدايه الحرب
الاسرائيليه على القطاع وكانت مثل هذه
الاعداد تدخل يوميا قبل بدء الحرب مع كل
هذه الاحتياجات ما فائده الحديث عن 500
شاحنه تدخل في ظل كل هذا النقص
والاحتياج سيدتي المشكله الكبيره التي
تواجهنا جميعا الان هي نقص الوقود يعني
حتى مع دخول هذه شاحنات بعد دخولها هناك
صعوبه في التحرك والدخول الى المناطق التي
نحتاج ان نصل اليها بسبب نقص الامدادات
امدادات الوقود يعني البرنامج لديه بعض
المواد الغذائيه المتبقيه في المخازن لكن
الحصول على وقود يسمح لنا بالتحركات في
داخل غزه وايصال هذه المساعدات الى الناس
اصبح مشكله كبيره وبالتالي يعني اذا لم هي
كلها منظومه مرتبطه بعضها دخول هذه
الشاحنات محمله بالمواد الانسانيه هو ايضا
مرتبط بان يكون هناك توفر للقوط حتى تتحرك
الشاحنات وتنتقل من مكان الى اخر بالاضافه
الى هذا المخ المخابز ما هو يعني توفير
الخبز مرتبط
بتتوفر المياه النظيفه وايضا الوقود وهذه
اصبحت مواد نادره في داخل غزه وماذا عن
الممرات الامنه سيده عبير ايضا خاصه اذا
اراد هذه الاحتياجات ان تذهب باتجاه
المناطق الشماليه مدينه غزه وما وشمال
قطاع غزه ايضا المحافظه الشماليه وهناك
900000 من السكان موجودين في تلك المنطقه
وهم منقطعون عن باقي
القطاع صحيح يعني هي الازمه ازمه الوقود
ازمه الوصول الى كل المناطق في غزه سواء
كان هذا في الشمال او الجنوب او الوسط
بالاضافه الى هذا طبعا عمليه استهداف بعض
المنشات الحيويه مثل المخابز يعني احنا في
برنامج البزاي العالمي كنا نعمل مع حوالي
23 مخبز في بدايه هذا الصراع الان لم
يتبقى الا مخبز واحد فقط مادال يعمل اما
ان الاخرين اصابهم ضرر او في هناك نقص في
الوقود وبالتالي من توفير خبز خبز الحوالي
200000 شخص بصوره يوميه في بدايه يعني منذ
حوالي شهر الان لم نصل بالامس الا ال
14000 شخص وبالتالي يعني هي طبعا هناك
ازمه انسانيه
و نقص شديد في الغذاء في داخل غزه